we haven't had any communication or I
haven't particularly neither of the
other family members in a long time so
we've all been wondering what her
problem is with us and
um the idea that we know what it is
kind of weird because we don't know what
it is because we've never talked and
heard from her this is the first time
we've heard from her in three plus years
so that's obviously disconcerting now as
far as what she said is concerned you
know clearly uh we take I take issue
with what she said uh on every level
there was no money made on anything I
did one 2020 interview and I didn't
charge for that I only did that because
the pundits were making a big deal out
of the fact that my mother died of a
broken heart and it was really annoying
me because I didn't agree with that
analysis then months and months later I
wrote my personal Memoirs called my
girls which is a book about my sister
and my mother and our life together over
60 years and in that book it's an homage
to them and it's not about their death
it's about their life this is my story
and I told my story and I wrote it
myself and it is not a tell-all book by
any stretched imagination and it's a
shame you know that that she hasn't
taken the time to read it but the
reality is is that uh you know it's hard
to judge when you haven't read it I am
big enough to say that I know that Kerry
would want us all not only to be friends
but to have a relationship there is a
benefit to having a relationship with
the only full-blood relative alive I
would say that I would be always open to
having a relationship with her but if
she doesn't want one I certainly don't
have any intentions of making an effort
to force it upon her she's made it very
clear for the first time in many years
that this is what she wants she's we're
persona non grata you know you could
read her words are very firm I think
they're completely misguided and based
on erroneous assumptions as I've
outlined it but um I I just think that
I'm I'm here whenever she wants to uh to
come back to the fold so to speak but I
if she doesn't want to that's that's her
choice it's a shame I'd love to know her
children I'd love to be in in their
world but she clearly thinks that I
would be some sort of a bad influence on
them because I wrote that book you know
and and uh allegedly made money on it
[Music]